[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a esta edición especial
del debate de France 24 el 2022 intentó
ser el año de la recuperación de la
renovación o transición para la región
de América Latina una región que todavía
no logra tener cohesión la integración
sigue siendo la deuda pendiente de la
región de América Latina el 2022 fue un
año electoral que significó también
virajes en términos políticos como
significó el caso de Colombia y El caso
de Brasil también significó crisis
política como sucedió o sucede en Perú
radicalización de posturas como sucedió
en El Salvador y profundización en la
polarización de la sociedad y a nivel
político como ha venido sucediendo en
Argentina en chile y también significó
una nueva oportunidad para tener una
nueva digamoslo así visibilidad a nivel
internacional como es el caso de
Venezuela Pero hay temas que son comunes
para toda la región la crisis económica
las dificultades para hacer frente a la
inflación el de los precios la
depreciación de las monedas locales fue
algo común en mayor o menor medida para
todos los países de la región de América
Latina Eso sí la pobreza sigue latente
la desigualdad Por supuesto que también
no ha habido ningún gobierno de
izquierda o de derecha que haya podido
hacerle frente de manera efectiva a
estas dos problemáticas en nuestra
región Y por supuesto el 2022 pues sigue
siendo un año en donde esto vuelve a
quedar en evidencia por eso en esta
edición especial vamos a hacer un
balance de lo que significó el 2022 para
América Latina en materia política en
materia económica social y cuáles son
los retos que habrá para el 2023 pues
para analizar y para conversar sobre
estos temas hemos invitado a Marta lagos
analista internacional economista
directora de la encuestadora regional
latimarómetro también está con nosotros
Katy segarra ellas politóloga de la
pontificia Universidad Católica de Perú
es magister en ciencia política y aquí
en el estudio de France 24 nos acompaña
Manuel González en ciencia política es
docente e investigador de la pontificia
universidad javeriana Universidad que
queda en la ciudad de Bogotá a nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
son parte de esta discusión de este
debate especial dejen sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales ya lo saben estamos en Twitter
en Facebook y también en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24@sántilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que ustedes
dejen todos los comentarios numeral el
debate f-24 todo junto todo pegado no
olviden también que todos los contenidos
de este programa también están
disponibles en diferentes plataformas de
podcast no se encuentran en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Marta y preguntándole por un panorama
general de la situación en América
Latina un breve resumen de lo que
significó este año para la región de
América Latina Marta bienvenida adelante
Bueno muy buenas tardes Buenos días
la verdad es que América Latina viene en
declive su democracia desde el año 2010
y termina la década del con el año 19
con tres países que tienen explosiones
sociales después viene la pandemia y
cuando empezamos a salir de la pandemia
que uno podría decir es el año 22
se produce una gran especulación
respecto de bueno Qué pasó con la
democracia Qué pasó con
el proceso económico y lo que nos
encontramos es de que no solo se
proyectan o se continúan las tendencias
que se habían visto en los años
anteriores es decir hay alternancias en
el poder en todos los países donde hubo
elección presidencial
deja detrás una élite y se elige a la
contraria No es cierto y eso lleva por
supuesto a esta alternancia que mucha
gente dice que es una ola de izquierda
esto lo que es es la desesperación de
los pueblos encontrar gobernantes que
finalmente encuentren las herramientas
que permitan salir de la desigualdad de
la pobreza y de la crisis económicas y
para eso lo que hacen los
electores latinoamericanos es elegir al
bando contrario entonces hay que tener
cuidado con decir que esto es una ola
porque la ola pueden permanecer como lo
sucedieron en el pasado yo creo que
ahora de aquí en adelante lo que vamos a
ver es una sucesión de alternancias El
que no lo hace bien hasta luego y lo
estamos viendo en el caso del Perú no no
les gustó como era el presidente lo que
estaba haciendo presidente el presidente
intentó tomar el poder Más allá de lo
que le permitía a las leyes y el
presidente termina siendo derrocado
entonces o tomado preso en por un
proceso constitucional que ya no no lo
deja fuera de la presidencia entonces
ojo porque estamos en una etapa distinta
de la región donde sí se produce que la
soberanía del pueblo manda más que lo
que mandaba antes hoy día los pueblos
sacan a los gobernantes de sus lugares
si no lo hacen bien y eso vale para los
y vale para los no populistas ya vimos
que bolsonaro perdió la elección es
decir los populistas también son sacados
de sus cargos Sí Marta gran diferencia
con el pasado un panorama general
describe entonces en la democracia la
alternancia la búsqueda de soluciones
por parte del pueblo y la necesidad de
hacerse sentir por parte de las
sociedades breve resumen de lo que ha
hecho nuestra invitada Voy a preguntarle
ahora a Katy su panorama general que
destaca de este 2022 de nuestra región y
que debemos tener en cuenta de
proyecciones para el 20 23 Punto de
partida
qué tal Muchas gracias por la invitación
Bueno yo coincido con varios puntos
respectiva que ha mencionado Laura no el
el hecho de que la ciudadanía ha
generado un o ha buscado un cambio de lo
que se tenía previo a la a la pandemia
en parte por la grave crisis económica y
sanitaria que está significado la busca
de renovación de los de los gobiernos
que se han tenido
bien Ha sido tanto de derecha como de
izquierda y no la generación de estas
olas hay una cuestión que también me
parece muy importante destacar que en
los últimos años ha estado
O especialmente este último año hemos
escuchado mucho las palabras de fraude a
pesar de que esta no ha habido esto por
ejemplo puede ser en el caso de Brasil
tanto de Perú en el cual se ha estado
cuestionando los resultados electorales
especialmente
han sido muy apretados o han tenido un
resultado distinto de lo que señalaban
las encuestadoras y esto significa clave
claramente un ataque hacia la democracia
otro tema creo que sería fundamental de
señalar es esta búsqueda Ciudadana de
de reclamos de mayor justicia social no
es y además las búsquedas de cambio de
Constitución creo que también llama
mucho la atención ese proceso
Constituyente de chile en también en el
Perú se ha buscado cambiar la
Constitución bueno había una un pequeño
grupo que ha buscado cambiar la
Constitución el presidente también había
llamado una asamblea Constituyente y en
general es esta cuestión esta búsqueda
de la ciudadanía de participar más a
partir de una democracia directa una
democracia directa las denuncias en los
interrogantes en los procesos
electorales y los reclamos ciudadanos en
resumen lo que ha dicho Katy para
comenzar este panorama general finalizó
aquí en el 24 con Manuel Manuel
Bienvenido al programa Gracias por
acompañarnos hoy y su panorama general
de la región que nos deja el 2022 Muchas
gracias por la invitación Santiago yo
creo que América Latina le apostó la
recuperación sin embargo es una región
que siempre ha sido vulnerable en su
historia y se digamos
afrontado tres graves crisis primero una
crisis que es netamente económica una
estanflación es decir tenemos bajo
crecimiento pero también alta inflación
y eso conduce a una segunda crisis la
crisis social y es una crisis social que
viene arrastrándose desde el 2019 y que
se agudizó con la con el covid 19 y los
gobiernos no pudieron solucionar ese
problema de Cómo afrontar la pobreza
Pero obviamente también como paliar la
desigualdad de hecho incluso los datos
de que nos dejó la pandemia fue que
regresamos a datos o a dígitos del 2002
por ejemplo entonces eran básicamente
como casi dos décadas de retroceso en
ese progreso y obviamente algo que
coincido con mis colegas es que todo
hotel de lo económico más lo social
termina afectando la institucionalidad
política y es que obviamente buscamos
alternancia buscamos quien lo haga mejor
que el gobierno de turno Y obviamente
Aquí sí debo decir yo que efectivamente
ese movimiento anti gobierno de turno Sí
ya favoreció a la izquierda de las cinco
de la cierta direcciones Perdón que al
final de cuentas se han disputado entre
2020 y 2022 pues cinco han sido para
organizaciones o partidos de izquierda
solamente dos han ganado la derecha Pero
obviamente eso digamos obedece a ese
cambio que quiere la gente frente al
gobierno de turno independiente Si es de
izquierda o es derecha Pero obviamente
América Latina se encuentra ante una
crisis que no es una crisis que se ha
buscado a sí misma sino que es una
crisis que tiene que ver con que no
tiene mecanismos resilientes para
afrontar choques externos Claro porque
aquí hay varios digamos efectos que han
caído en la región y que son por hechos
que ni siquiera están sucediendo en la
región estoy hablando Por ejemplo del de
la guerra en Ucrania que ya lo vamos a
tratar más adelante en el programa El
impacto que esto tiene en la región de
América Latina no sé si ustedes están de
acuerdo conmigo que tal vez lo que más
llama la atención en términos políticos
en la región ustedes lo mencionaban son
estos gobiernos o países que han hecho
la alternancia se han ido hacia la
izquierda pero si vemos el mapa general
son ya la mayoría de países de la región
que están gobernados por un gobierno de
turno que pertenece a ese gran espectro
que tiene la izquierda latinoamericana
porque no se puede hablar de una misma
izquierda uniforme hay diferencias entre
ellos quiero que lo hablemos ya ustedes
decían una necesidad de alternancia qué
más llevó a que América Latina tuviera
que tomar estas opciones se enrutara por
ese lado y Qué significa esto para la
construcción democrática porque también
hay que decir que en América Latina las
democracias son relativamente jóvenes
hago la ronda la inversa entonces
comienzo con Manuel aquí en el estudio
de France 24 la alternancia siempre es
saludable para la democracia es decir
democracias que no tienen alternancia
terminan digamos generando hegemonías y
esas hegemonías al final de cuentas
terminan construyendo instituciones muy
autoritarias Pero qué es lo que sucede
estas alternancias no vienen muy sólidas
en términos legislativos es decir
tenemos que son presidentes que llegan o
por coaliciones y esas coaliciones se
han desgastando con el tiempo y terminan
generando problemas de gobernabilidad o
efectivamente sucede que son presidentes
que llegan al gobierno pero no tiene
mayoría parlamentaria por lo tanto les
es difícil de alguna forma los
presidentes cumplir sus mandatos
populares y obviamente se enfrentan a
otro mandato popular que son los
mandatos de los congresos eso obviamente
tenemos un problema de legitimidad Dual
que uno llamaría en términos de ciencia
política y obviamente eso lo que genera
es que si bien la alternancia Es
saludable pero también engendra ciertos
problemas Cuál es el asunto ahí hay un
problema que están todos los actores y
es creer que la democracia es algo que
es un es como un partido largo siempre
hay la posibilidad de ser gobierno Y ser
la oposición pero lo que vemos es la
idea de la inmediatez de los de los
actores y por otro lado los diseños
institucionales vemos por ejemplo lo que
pasa en el Perú que hay incentivos
perversos de la misma reglas del juego
que permiten ese ingobernabilidad
entonces obviamente la alternancia
saludable pero también tiene sus
problemas que tienen que ser afrontados
desde las instituciones pero también
desde los actores que piensa Katy sobre
este viraje que dieron algunos países es
tal vez lo más representativo junto con
las crisis y la polarización que piensa
usted
Sí a ver
a Perú y y tanto Marta como Manuel han
mencionado a Perú creo que es importante
hacer un pequeño y paréntesis señalando
de que en general no es que las reglas
últimamente se han modificado a tal
punto de que han generado esta
destrucción entre poderes y la búsqueda
de romper El Ejecutivo y legislativo si
no son los mismos actores quizás más
adelante podríamos conversarlo un poco
más creo que un tema también fundamental
dentro de la política latinoamericana
que hemos estamos viendo con mayor
fuerza es esta polarización no que
también le habían mencionado Manuel en
el sentido de cómo se presentan las
fuerzas en el parlamento así como Cómo
se presenta se presentan las fuerzas
dentro del gobierno lo que tenemos
mayoritariamente o sea o lo que estamos
teniendo Es que muchos gobiernos entran
sin mayoría no y está claro que estos
genera dificultades en la gobernabilidad
por otro lado y continuando con la que
había comentado de la polarización creo
que eso está presentando bastante No es
decir tanto en el Perú en Brasil en en
Chile la degradación de los partidos
políticos y la el posicionamiento de
ciertos tópicos que generan como dije
esa polarización ciudadana por ejemplo
uno de los grandes tomados
Lamentablemente tiende a ser todo el
tema de derechos de las mujeres y de la
comunidad lgtbiq es decir el tema de
género tiende a generar esa polarización
y es tomada por los líderes políticos
para posicionarse tanto totalmente en
contra como en el caso de bolso es decir
un gobierno muy conservador como
búsqueda de este posiciones mucho más
progresistas que podría ser el caso de
boric en chile sí y cerramos esta ronda
con Marta Marta su opinión sobre esta
alternancia como usted lo ha llamado
este viraje que han dado algunos países
en la región antes de entrar al tema de
la estabilidad
Bueno hay que tomar en cuenta que de las
últimas 19 elecciones presidenciales que
han tenido lugar desde el año 19 en
América Latina Solo dos no han tenido
alternancia entonces a mí me parece que
eso es lo dominante ahora por qué se
produce esa alternancia se produce
porque a lo largo de la década del 2010
No es cierto después del Gran Puma
económico que llevó a la crisis de la
Democracia del año 2008
eh a lo largo de la década del 2010 se
vino
erosionando el sistema de partidos es
decir
lo vimos en Perú en la última elección
parlamentaria No es cierto hubieron
dieciséis partidos que quedaron afuera
del sistema Porque no alcanzaron el
mínimo de votos entre ellos estaban
todos los partidos tradicionales del
Perú Entonces todos los partidos que
entraron a gobernar en este nuevo
escenario eran partidos relativamente
nuevos Y algunos del todo nuevos en esa
fragmentación Y con esa composición la
goberna ya se hace prácticamente
imposible aquí hay un problema de la
atomización del sistema de partidos que
sucede en Brasil que sucede en en
Colombia vimos en Colombia como en el
último minuto aparece un candidato
afuera del sistema de partidos vimos en
Chile también hoy día tenemos diecinueve
partidos representados en la en el
parlamento antes eran seis entonces la
dificultad de gobernar tiene que ver con
la fragmentación la dificultad para
armar coaliciones que piensen
relativamente igual para encontrar
consensos para pasar leyes y la
alternancia viene también de la
ineficacia de esos gobiernos que no
tiene no teniendo mayoría no pueden
pasar leyes es una ecuación bastante
simple que de digamos de relatar y muy
compleja de remediar porque para poder
remediar los gobiernos al primero que
remediar el sistema de partidos O sea si
nosotros no somos capaces de
reconstituir un sistema de partidos
sólido en América Latina que
efectivamente
representen interpreten recojan las
demandas del pueblo y sean capaces de
responder a esas demandas vamos a irnos
de alternancia en alternancia de
populismo de populismo es sin poder
resolver el tema de la desigualdad y el
tema No es cierto de que hoy día se han
agregado cincuenta millones de
latinoamericanos a la Pobreza debido a
la pandemia decir se le suma a lo que ya
existía
los cincuenta millones adicionales de
pobres por lo tanto yo diría vamos a
vivir una década pensando un poquitito
en el futuro vamos a vivir una década
sumamente difícil
su gobierno van a tener que gobernar con
este sistema de fragmentación Marta
justamente le quería preguntar
moviéndonos al tema de la de la
inestabilidad de la región que podemos
esperar entonces para el 2023
entendiendo este dato que usted suma que
es la atomización política la
atomización de los partidos la
ineficacia de estos gobiernos para para
llevar las riendas de los países y esto
y esta alternancia Entonces qué podemos
esperar en términos de estabilidad para
el 2023 teniendo en cuenta que la crisis
económica que están pronosticando
todavía no ha golpeado del todo como
Esperamos que golpea los países de la
región si es que llega a golpear tan
fuerte como están pronosticando los los
analistas Pero qué podemos entonces
esperar marchas manifestaciones
ciudadanas golpes de estado cómo lo ve
usted
Mire yo creo que el año 23 va a ser un
año de crisis de crisis económica y como
sabemos como dice la teoría lo dice
hitchmann con todas sus letras cuando
hay crisis económica la gente se encarga
de tratar de comer y no hay revoluciones
las revoluciones no suceden nunca cuando
no hay pan no las revoluciones suceden
cuando hay pan es decir si esperamos No
es cierto A que hayan grandes
levantamientos sociales aquellos van a
suceder Una vez que se haya hecho alguna
recuperación económica que permita que
la gente ya tenga pan arriba de su mesa
y no tenga que salir a pelear por el pan
No es cierto a pelear por el pedazo de
comida me parece que por eso el año 23
va a ser un año en términos de
movimientos sociales relativamente
Pacífico con una gigantesca presión
sobre los gobiernos nuevos y los viejos
claro para
apalear la crisis y la diferencia con la
crisis del 2010 es de que en el año 2010
una pequeña
billetera no cierto de parte de los
países que permitió hacer una política
económica contra cíclica es decir hacer
transferencias directas pero con la
pandemia los países han quedado sin
billetera porque se gastaron todo el
dinero que tenía Entonces ahora no
pueden aplanar la crisis Entonces eso
eso va a resultar en ingobernabilidades
Sí Marta paso a preguntarle a Manuel
sobre la opinión que tiene sobre cómo
van a ser estos gobiernos de izquierda
que la apuestan tanto a los proyectos
sociales como dice Marta sin una
billetera disponible porque no hay este
flujo de caja ni hay este crecimiento
económico que tuvieron los países de
izquierda en esa ola previa digámoslo
así Donde había un Boom de commodities
donde Brasil le estaba vendiendo al
mundo entero donde el petróleo
enriquecía las arcas venezolanas hoy en
día el panorama es muy distinto que se
puede esperar entonces de esos gobiernos
efectivamente lo has dicho y es que la
izquierda del pasado no es la izquierda
del presente simplemente por una
cuestión muy que es la renta digamos de
las commodities y obviamente si lo que
hemos visto de este pequeño viraje en
términos políticos de los gobiernos que
tiran a la izquierda gracias a esa
alternancia lo que hemos visto es que se
han Unido con fuerzas no digamos
conservadoras pero sí tal vez más
moderadas y eso lo que le ha permitido a
los a los partidos de izquierda y
obviamente a sus electorados es por un
lado acallar las voces que dicen de que
la izquierda digamos va a impulsar
programas ambiciosos eternos de
redistribución de la riqueza y Que
obviamente va a generar muchos
distorsiones económicas pero por el otro
lado mantener una política fiscal
incluso monetaria muy responsable
obviamente esto lo hemos visto en el
caso de Honduras lo hemos visto en el
caso por ejemplo de Colombia en el caso
por ejemplo incluso de países como por
ejemplo Brasil ahorita con con Lula y
esto lo que favorece al final de cuentas
es que el electorado y obviamente el
mercado que es el electorado silencioso
pues se mantenga en calma Qué puede
suceder y manteniendo las expectativas
porque eso es algo que los buenos tienen
que mantener las expectativas cuando no
se llegan a cumplir esas expectativas
pueden empezar a ver problemas y esos
problemas se pueden traducir en
manifestaciones en protestas pero por
ahora lo que podemos ver Es que estos
gobiernos han manejado muy bien las
expectativas porque han aterrizado sus
propuestas de campaña gracias a esas
alianzas esas coaliciones compartidos
más moderados con actores más moderados
que permiten aterrizar Y ser más viables
esos programas de redistribución y
obviamente de responsabilidad fiscal
Katy le preguntó usted Aprovechando que
usted está en Lima que está en Perú su
país lleva prácticamente seis años en un
bucle de crisis política constante
digamos que sea agudizado en las últimas
semanas con todos los acontecimientos en
torno al expresidente Pedro castillo qué
podemos esperar y le hago la pregunta
específicamente de Perú porque es tal
vez la crisis política más complicada
que estamos viendo en la región para
este cierre de año que podemos esperar
para el 2023 será una etapa de
transición además que voy a ir una cosa
Pero puede que esté en una profunda
crisis de gobernabilidad y una crisis
política pero económicamente le está
yendo muy bien si lo comparamos con
otros países de la región que nadie
puede hacer un análisis certero de Por
qué funciona la economía y la política
no
es muy extraño en el caso peruano una
de las
Por qué a pesar tenemos un crecimiento
como e importante en comparación del
resto de la región es que las
instituciones que
ven la economía por ejemplo el bcr en
mismo Ministerio de economía y y genera
otras instituciones que manejan pues
este las normativas económicas en el
Perú están bastante limitadas o tienen
un espacio fuera de ese caos político es
decir son instituciones bastante
tecnócratas que además cuentan con
personas las personas más especializadas
por ejemplo en economía del Perú tenemos
al presidente de en el Banco Central de
reserva que ha visto Julio Velarde ha
visto alrededor de siete presidentes no
decir tenemos solamente a un presidente
del bcr que ha visto esos cambios
políticos constantes en en gobierno pero
que este se mantiene Entonces esta creo
que es una de las principales razones
por las cuales la economía va en una vía
distinta al caos político y ahora
respondiendo tu pregunta Sobre qué es lo
que esperaría Yo quisiera ser un poco
más
más positiva Pero cuesta bastante No en
el sentido de que si bien por ejemplo la
presidente Dina boluarte ha pedido
elecciones Y eso pareciese que fuese el
camino que busca calmar la crisis
política entre ejecutivo y legislativo
Lamentablemente y como bien lo había
señalado Marta los partidos políticos
están en degradación y en ese sentido Es
difícil tener una buena representación y
políticos responsables Y es que esto
miran de manera muy cortoplacista Y eso
es lo que sucede Y entonces así que a
pesar de que hayan elecciones Eso no
significa el fin de la crisis la
incertidumbre es lo que domina ahora el
escenario político peruano todos los
días sucede algo que sorprende aún más
cuando uno cree que ya el país tocó
fondo algo nuevo sucede en Perú y es un
poco también lo que pasa con Argentina
en términos económicos cuando uno cree
que ya la economía Argentina no da más
el país logra dar un paso y por lo menos
dar un paso hacia la recuperación o un
paso más hacia profundizar la crisis
económica son países bastante complejos
si los analizamos desde ese punto de
vista quiero que escalemos esto un poco
fuera de las fronteras de América Latina
y nos vayamos a mirar las realidades de
lo que está sucediendo en otros rincones
del planeta Katy continuo con usted en
la Ciudad de Lima y los efectos que
pueden tener en nuestra región la guerra
en Ucrania que se extendió más de lo que
estábamos esperando ya va a cumplir
prácticamente un año en febrero del 2023
ya se cumple un año del inicio de la
invasión también lo que está sucediendo
en Estados Unidos en términos políticos
y en términos económicos ellos las tasas
de interés inmediatamente la inflación
en América Latina recibe el golpe y las
monedas locales se deprecian frente al
Dólar y también lo que decía china que
es muy importante porque ya es un actor
comercial muy importante en la región de
América Latina qué análisis puede hacer
usted de perspectiva para el 2023 de
esos tres actores
bueno está claro que
estos los tres sectores que tú mencionas
y su actuar político económico y militar
son o tienen un efecto principal y y muy
fuerte dentro de la economía de América
Latina lo cual es generado por ejemplo
la devaluación de todas las monedas en
en este en este continente no entonces
lo que se espera Y lamentablemente es
que no al menos no se sabe cuándo
terminará por ejemplo esta guerra en
Ucrania se esperaría que
que acabe pronto pero no parece que
hubieran las luces para que para que
esto suceda por otro lado el
fortalecimiento del dólar ha generado
graves problemas a diversas economías
especialmente en la Argentina en la
chilena me parece también
lo que ha generado Pues que los precios
que las monedas primer lugar se devalúen
y por otro lado que el interés de la de
de los préstamos en América Latina se
vuelan mucho más costosos no y es claro
también de que este china
especialmente en este en este uso de del
compras masivas de de materias primas
también tenía un rol fundamental eso lo
podíamos ver en Perú hace diez años
donde china era un socio comercial
importantísimo en el cual el hecho eh de
la modificación dentro de su economía
afecta directamente y así podemos ver
como América Latina es bastante
sensible eso y Su economía es bastante
vulnerable mejor dicho ante los cambios
internacionales estamos llegando a la
parte final del programa pero quiero
conocer la opinión de de Manuel sobre
este tema una perspectiva rápida muy
puntual por favor de estos tres actores
internacionales básicamente América
tiene está entre los dos gigantes en
este caso Estados Unidos y China y
obviamente lo que pasa en Rusia con la
invasión a Ucrania pues obviamente tiene
una un efecto muy grave en términos de
la inflación por la evacuación de los
fertilizantes eso tiene digamos una
digamos un efecto en términos del alza
de precios de los alimentos obviamente
también está el factor energético un
factor digamos que es muy importante
para América Latina debido a su digamos
naturaleza en términos de las
commodities y obviamente lo que pasa con
china también está relacionado con la
cuestión de la política de covid cero
que ha impulsado es que obviamente
mientras la gente esté confinada pues
obviamente no va a haber comercio y eso
digamos digamos limita mucho el campo de
acción que tiene América Latina para
exportar y obviamente con los Estados
Unidos pues lo que se trata de manejar
con Estados Unidos obviamente la idea de
las tasas digamos del tipo de cambio y
eso tiene un impacto muy sensible en
América Latina y eso aumentar digamos el
precio de la deuda Pues también y
digamos quiebra mucho esa posibilidad
que tengan los gobiernos de tratar de
generar Pero también es generar
desarrollo entonces América Latina se
encuentra en un laberinto entre esos
tres gigantes digámoslo en ese caso de
China Estados Unidos y obviamente lo que
está pasando con Rusia en Ucrania para
este último bloque quiero que hablemos
de las perspectivas voy a dejar una
buena cantidad de minutos para que
puedan hacer ustedes las conclusiones de
lo que viene para el 2023 para nuestra
región Qué hechos relevantes hay que
tener en cuenta yo mencionaría uno por
lanzar uno sobre la mesa para que lo
tomen como ejemplo pero creo que la lupa
también va a estar por ejemplo a lo
largo del año en esos diálogos que están
avanzando entre el gobierno colombiano y
la guerrilla del eln y la apertura de la
frontera entre Colombia y Venezuela la
apertura completa y el restablecimiento
de esas relaciones va a ser un hecho al
que le vamos a ir haciendo seguimiento a
lo largo del año desde la perspectiva de
ustedes qué hechos pueden ser destacados
para el 2023 Y si quieren hacer
perspectiva para la región o para un
país en particular les dejo la palabra
comienzo entonces con Marta para su
conclusión adelante
Bueno mira A mí me gustaría comenzar
diciendo que yo creo que la pandemia nos
deja en una situación de vulnerabilidad
América Latina frente a la globalización
que termina de dominar previo a la
pandemia a la globalización era bastante
más moderada lo que soy y uno de los
ejemplos es el tema de las vacunas No es
cierto ahí nos dimos cuenta hasta qué
punto Nosotros somos lo que somos que
somos países pequeños que no tenemos
poder no tenemos presencia internacional
América Latina es terriblemente débil en
el contexto internacional y terminamos
siendo con la excepción de Brasil y
México No es cierto terminamos siendo
simple espectadores y como espectadores
tenemos todas las consecuencias y
ninguna capacidad de reacción por lo
tanto desde la perspectiva de América
Latina América Latina Debería ser capaz
no cierto hoy día de
aunarse en términos de poder defenderse
un poco frente a estos temas
globalización para tener un poquitito
más de poder en el concierto
internacional eso yo creo que es un
punto que viene que se va a plantear
porque no podemos llegar al desarrollo
en el grado de debilidad y de
vulnerabilidad como países que estamos
en el frente al mundo Y en segundo lugar
yo diría desde el punto de vista interno
de los países evidentemente lo que usted
menciona respecto de Venezuela y
Colombia hace sentido porque porque
resulta que la estrategia de no
considerar las dictaduras y de hacer
como si esta fueran irrelevantes y dejar
que siguieran digamos su curso no
resultó no y por lo tanto cambiar la
estrategia Y tratar no cierto de influir
en lo que hacen los otros países es no
es una no es una mala estrategia y por
lo tanto me parece que hay que tener con
mucho mucho cuidado hay que mirar qué es
lo que pasa con Venezuela y Colombia hay
que mirar también la capacidad de del
gobierno de de enfrentar la la violencia
que es
un gran mal que aqueja a la región Katy
la conclusión rápidamente por favor muy
puntual
si quiero ser muy puntual creo que mi
mayor preocupación va a ser el sistema
democrático de América Latina y ya que
Perú se ha puesto mucho en en tendencia
por estas graves crisis políticas unas
pequeñas palabras sobre este país es muy
importante y vamos a estar muy atentos
respecto a la búsqueda no quiebre
democrático creo que esa es la mayor
preocupación dentro de los peruanos pero
también cómo es que los políticos van a
comportarse de manera responsable
buscando la representación sin embargo
parece que no vienen sentidos para ello
mucho más allá de esta búsqueda de
ciudadanía además que el tema además que
el tema de Perú también está generando
divisiones entre los gobiernos de la
región entre quienes apoyan a quienes y
en qué bando están Y eso tampoco le
conviene a la región para el cierre
Manuel un minuto para la conclusión
adelante yo creo que hay tres desafíos
primero crisis migratorias
Venezuela son digamos dos puntos
calientes digamos de esta crisis
migratoria obviamente también está la
cuestión de México y todos los migrantes
Centroamericanos está también la
cuestión de la Democracia es un tema
digamos que está latente es decir al
final de cuentas lo que pasa en El
Salvador lo que pasa en otros países
donde efectivamente no vemos golpes de
fuerza sino que vemos sutiles rupturas
del orden constitucional pues obviamente
es algo que radicalización como la
radicalista dentro exactamente digamos
ha cambiado esa sutileza en cómo
subvertir las reglas democráticas y
finalmente yo creo que también la la
crisis que persiste que creo que es como
la llaman así la materia que tienen que
aprobar muchos gobiernos es la crisis
económica es decir yo creo que eso es
algo que va a persistir es algo que
mientras América Latina no tenga los
mecanismos resilientes Pues no va a
poder digamos digamos crecer y
obviamente reescribir su amplia riqueza
Pues a Marta Katia Manuel les agradezco
por este balance de el año 2022 para
nuestra región para América Latina
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros En nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos su sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera siga
con nosotros
[Música]